siamo arrivati a quel momento della
nostra vita quando fanno uscire secondo
di un gioco popolarissimo va bene allora
play
allora ragazzi in questo gioco di baldi
credo che non lo so come faccia nasconde
su due alberi che capita nascondere
prove a fosse entrata dentro
va bene si apre slam ma anche veloci
sono tutti gli effetti sonori pro orca
[ __ ]
no no no non sto correndo porca [ __ ]
non mi ricordo ragazzi le cose che
succedono in ball dice in base a quello
che fai imprendi anche delle punizioni
ad esempio non puoi correre nei corridoi
se quello ti vede sono ci mette di
punizione e baldi arriva quindi va bene
sta arrivando
sta arrivando sta arrivando avrei già
dovuto fare dei passi da gigante ma non
ho fatto niente sono stato fermo tutto
il tempo quindi speriamo il suo è un suo
fermo salerno 1 correndo meraviglioso
quando spunta alla faccia sua non ho
capito se si sta accorgendo del fatto
che esisto oppure no magari non gliene
frega niente time alarm clock cosa vi
serve picking non ho capito cosa mi deve
servire prova davanti al avanti dato al
piano di sopra teoricamente perché vedo
l'islanda sopra è utilissimo prendere
ragazzi e beh veramente utili su con i
sottotitoli perché vedi dove c'è begli
vedi esattamente più o meno la sua
posizione che di molto di sopra non è di
sopra quindi non serva un calcio
qualcosa qui bevilo bevilo bellina so da
chi magari recuperi vita cerco per
l'energia veloce però quanto tempo ho
trovato due su quattro notti books
incroci in totale c'è un telefono vicolo
cieco questo dio ti prego salva nord
a posto ho preso due notebook su quattro
non è male magari facciamo credo ragazzi
che i notebook siano sparsi
effettivamente
non ho becco lo qua uno qui sono quelli
verdi allora la moneta dovrei ricordarmi
esattamente che cosa fanno tutte le cose
ma non è così purtroppo non mi dicono
non sega vai vai vai zio io ti seguo
perché poi ecco altro notebook ti seguo
anche da quella parte lì perché
effettivamente non so dove sono i noto
che credo che paolino a caso non lo sto
correndo non sto correndo non so come i
dotti che la punta credo sia poi dietro
si è qua vedo se disco raggirarlo non
altro modo
ok porca pupazza aiuto
no mi ha fregato tantissimo è
difficilissimo del premio di tutti e
quattro li prenderò finché 4 mesbah
finché non li prendono continua ecco
time secondo me se lo uso quando c'è
baldini da un sacco di tempo in più per
magari mi sbaglio non è così ok energy
flower una cassetta utile anna baker
esci ti giuro che non l'avessero quindi
adesso teoricamente baldi potrebbe
essere distratto dalla cassetta speriamo
di sì speriamo di sì spero di sì no noi
gliene fregava niente era gip live ok
ripresenta l'energia ottimo l'energia
flavour serve recupare tutta l'energia
quando sei morto fantastico se siamo a
tre
siamo tre su quattro ragazzi fantastico
questo non è male questo non è male
questo non è male questo non è male non
è male 24 li ho presi gli istituti sono
finito vinto sono forte sotto la le leve
di tor posso tornare l'evento che quello
è aperto sta correndo lo zio ho fatto
una scoreggia buco lui con oggetto lì e
lì e lì dice la faccio ce l'ho fatta
sono fortissimo ho vinto e sono molto
figo che sarà la versione normale ivaldi
comunque non è facile ci sono bisogna
sfruttare anche veli gli oggetti perché
quello fa tanto
a 0 su 6 cui all'inizio minchiate in
tutta la modalità se magari poi andiamo
avanti abbiamo capito cosa fa la
barretta energetica vediamo se
scoprendone 6
dubito odio che capta le mat machine
design not diet finals e meno 4 fa 2 2
ei grazie ecco un outlook posso uscire
acqua baldi è fermo perché non sbaglio
qualcosa è vero che baldi parte solo
quando sbagli qualcosa
no è partito a cazzo scherzavo è molto
più bello questo arco demonio non ho
capito questo è successo ho preso
l'autobus della squadra ragazzi mi ha
portato in campeggio non ho capito il
senso di tutto questo però vabbè
comunque fatto molto meglio del primo
secondo me c'è tanta roba in più o 160
secondi per fare cosa ci sono dei culi
nel cielo di tutti non possono anche
cose no no no no no chao ma lui è andato
il campeggio qui ci sta siamo tornati a
22 notebook quindi a posto perche questa
e la school facoltà ai ragazzi non ho
più energia più succede un santo di dio
fatto un giro si sta allagando ragazzi
la scuola il titanic riprende la fecola
succede stato il dio e che sta
succedendo sto capendo cosa sta
succedendo dove baldi è lì che anch'io
io devo fare un giro stranissimo purity
non si può chiudere la vetta non ho
capito se facendo il giro lo fregato
noah mi sa che non lo fregato
e vabbè ed è voci di qualunque quindi
prova ci vai è rimasto incastrato forse
non so se rimastica stato ma potrebbe
esserlo
credo di sì posso recuperare energia per
chi è rimasto incastrato nella porta
questo è ottimo questa un'ottima news
meno male perché l'energia stava 0 e
l'acqua lo staff ottendo ottima la
doveva dono di qua cammina cammina tanto
rimasto sei rimasto bloccato
speriamo rimanga bloccato ancora per un
botto ragazzi speriamo
sono fermo meno male non fa niente se
stanno avuto si allaga tutto vero che
intanto non è colpa mia
swiss re ci sia ora è no non è più
allagato cazzo era utilissimo
non ho capito niente ma c'è quello la
che spara cosa quindi vado di qua questa
porta è chiusa porco demonio porco
maledizione le porte chi ci manca solo
quello chi è quel tizio orribile devo
fare il giro lo farà giro mi servono mi
serve la barretta energetica mi
servirebbe la barretta enel sarebbe
testa di culo java questo ho capito non
si è fatto va beh meno male anzi meno
male mi ha messo in detention in questo
momento mi servì a tantissimo perché ero
proprio davanti a baldi quindi facente
per recuperare l'energia teoricamente se
non ho sfiga
mi sa che sfiga ho avuto sfiga proviamo
ancora beyoncé di far ripartire al 6 da
vi fa ripartire da sé è difficilissimo
ragazzi perché non trovo il postino li
trovo alan toc non so cosa serve alla
massa arriva baldi lo uso 0 dello zero
eccolo qua lo zero a zero e da mini
notebook grazie
molto bene raga mancano due notebook non
ho idea di dove siano manca uno stop non
ci credono sto bene così vicino ma con
la troupe solo notebook sono un book
vinto
ti prego fatelo a trovare non è che devo
andare lì perché non so se devo andare
vagoni che ormai velocissimo
no ragazzi non ho idea di dove sia non è
un'idea misuro secolo mi spara al cosa
sono morto
o forse no perché usa poi in sospetta
l'ho usato l'ho usato infatti non mi
hanno mia baldini da new ruler la rotta
la rotta ha rotto il coso quindi non mi
può prendere adesso si è rotto il
righello di baldi al ciclo come non
detto mi prende uguale salto il dio
eccola l'ultima l'altro l'ho trovato
aiuto dio santo madonna che se ne andò
ragazzi ho fatto una provata
fermi tutti zitti ho fatto una provata
ha fatto lavorare no no devi lo devi
toglierti vittorio di zio di torno mi
sparare
ho usato la scissa time time time non me
ne frega niente
avevo vinto da non tornare al elevator
ero vicino ai ragazzi normalmente vicino
però ogni volta ti prendi cosi baldi
diventa più forte
bellissimo per me o dieci volte meglio
del primo vero che vi sia piaciuto
bellissimo molto meglio del primo farò
sicuramente un altro episodio perché
spettacolare ci siamo ha proseguito di
baldi sarete dei tricks scrivetelo qua
sotto perché mi servono sempre visto che
in balli servono tanto è difficile e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo della
ragazza
[Musica]